so I do have maybe some news you guys
won't like what I knew we were throwing
away a lot of trash here at BuzzFeed but
I wanted to get some hard numbers about
how much exactly so we sorted through
347 pounds of trash and we discovered
that over 60% of what we were sending to
landfill was actually recyclable or
compostable we also found that we were
sending an estimated a thousand pounds
of recycling to landfill per week from
BuzzFeed this really bought me so I
decided we should do something about it
hi I have an announcement trying to get
signatures to get people to recycle I
will do my best to throw my recycling in
the blue recycling bins and not in the
black trash bin are you down to size
show of hands my goal was to reduce this
amount by 20% in one month I contacted
the company that takes out our trash
Athens and got in touch with their
sustainability manager Jessica to see if
there's something we could do so looking
at this area around us what what can we
do immediately to encourage people to
recycle you have a lot of trash cans at
every single desk there are no recycling
containers if you were to remove all of
those containers create a central
location where people can drop off their
recycling and their landfill it will
encourage people to recycle more so I do
have maybe some news you guys will like
we're getting rid of individual desk
trash cans it's a real thing
[Music]
you're gonna have to get up to a common
area and throw away your trash I think
it changes everything that's gonna be a
bummer because I'm really lazy person
but I'll get my steps in doesn't sit
well with me but I'll do it for the
earth for the earth
if the containers aren't set up
correctly if there's no signage if
people don't know what goes in the
container they're not gonna use it right
just make sure that your containers are
always grouped together recycling and
trash and then make sure there's signage
after much emailing and coordinating we
have this little trash station we did a
lot of work coming up with these signs
and these bins and so after our best
laid plans let's see if a mass of 400
people are actually following the signs
this has food in it so I'm like weird oh
I was able to figure out every single
thing and where it went
if I didn't have that I would have just
like dumped it all in the trash it's
baby steps okay oh she just threw misses
it's a scratch yes it does not this is
not no one you have to walk
it's why you need a friend like that to
push you to do things like going to the
gym okay this is all talk no action to
be fair we still have our personal trash
which is why she's taking it away I will
do better once the brush gets gone but I
was there my face early Monday morning
and all the personal trash cans are gone
this is my desk right now it's usually
messy but now it's a little bit more
messy because I got to get up to put
things places which is fine for the
environment it was frustrating at first
because I'm used to just throwing away
in the trash can which is like we're
right next to the desk but it was also
frustrating because I see how much I'm
producing in trash hashtag I'm faced
with my ways gas
[Applause]
if only people could read lot of things
are actually not acceptable
I don't even have to read the things
look I know napkins go with organic
silverware we'll go here because the
camera I don't know yeah we took them
away but you there's bigger creamers in
the main canteen the same now that we
have this new system I wanted to see if
we had gotten better and if we had
reduced the amount of recyclable and
compostable things we were sending to
landfill so we did another trash sort
with zero waste sky Jonathan did we
reach the 20% goal of redemption no we
came in at about thirteen and a half
percent given the fact you just made
some changes it's actually a really good
step in the right direction
whenever I dig in the trash cans which
is basically every day I still see
errors getting a large group of people
to change their habits is hard but most
people are sorting correctly BuzzFeed is
now recycling at a higher rate and
sending less food waste to landfill
which means less methane in the
atmosphere contributing to climate
change and for that I'm happy and proud
what can we get better up definitely
need to get better at keeping those
bottles and cans out of the trash put
them in a recycle bin and also focusing
on getting food waste into the compost
bin